Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
and I'm Link.
this week at the round table
of dim lighting, that's right.
We're back in our zone.
We're back at the table,
sitting a little further apart.
When we were at the other house--
Too close.
A little too close, a little too close.
I mean, we were not six feet apart best
because me and you are a pod.
We're never six feet
apart, let's be honest.
We're not, we don't
practice social distancing
between the two of us,
but this is a slightly
more social distance.
We are a partnership of creativity.
We got pod.
And that's why we're here.
We're a creative pod, who does a podcast.
This week at the round
table of the dim lighting.
We're gonna discuss our
relationship with board games.
I thought you're gonna
stop at relationship.
So many others thought the same thing.
I'm sure we'll talk
about our relationship.
And there's a number of relationships
that are impacted by this
board game conversation.
If you don't like it board
games, this podcast is for you.
And if you do like board games,
this podcast is also for you.
And if you're indifferent to board games
and you have sort of a, "I
mean, yeah, I'll take it.
"If somebody offers a
relationship with board games,"
this podcast is for you.
And by this podcast, we mean this episode
and the whole show.
Is a podcast episode, a podcast?
It's an episode.
I gotta ask you another question
because I didn't know
the answer to that one.
I just wanna sweep it under the rug.
You have an ants problems at your house.
It is so hot, I mean,
California is freaking burning.
It's sad.
Like I've looked at,
and it's so hot.
Like last week, it was
record breaking temperatures
in our zone, like 105 degree days.
And that's the interesting
thing that we discovered about
California that we didn't
know until we moved here.
Back in North Carolina,
September rolls around,
and yet it's still hot, but
it's starting to change.
It's starting to say,
"Okay okay okay, enough already."
Yeah, creeping up on fall.
But in Southern California,
September is like,
"We just getting started y'all."
I remember the first year we moved here--
August, September is really hot typically.
Yeah, I remember being 115
degrees in October in Burbank.
And I was like,
"I didn't think this is
what it was supposed to be."
So yeah, it's super hot--
But it's hotter than normal.
The fires are everywhere.
And I think that's why
like all of these insects
are now inside of my house.
You know it's hot when
it's too hot for an insect.
I mean, can an insect,
they're used to the a
hundred degree temperature.
They can do.
They have the exoskeleton.
Apparently they're sensitive
when it gets to that temperature.
'Cause I think that is the reason.
There's just,
like I looked at in Jade's dog bowl
and I went over there because
I knew there was still food in it.
But she was like, she'd
bark and she looked at me.
And I was like, "You're asking for food,
"but you've already got food."
Well, you know where this is going.
I'll walk over there.
There's more ants in the
bowls and there is food.
And then she doesn't, she's not,
ants are not on the menu.
Nope, she did not wanna eat the ants.
So like, I clean out the whole bowl.
And Christy starts, she found the spray,
I didn't even know I had it.
Oh, we got lots of sprays
because we deal with this.
What we--
All the time.
We got, I mean,
I got natural sprays that don't actually
harm the humans and the pets.
And then when things get real bad,
all bets are off and we
harm everyone, including us
unnatural sprays.
She let loose with this spray.
I mean, I've totally relocated Jade's bowl
to somewhere else because
I know that these ants
are talking to each other.
Cause there's a whole--
Pheromones.
There's a whole line of ant.
They like make a trail.
Trail of scent.
And then it's going up
and it's going like through something,
there's no hole next to
the window, but somehow--
Oh, they don't need a hole.
They don't need a hole,
they're just coming in.
I think that they can just
talk about teleportation.
It's like they copper filled it.
They're the ones who know how to teleport.
They copper filled it right
through the wall sometimes.
This morning, I went back into my bathroom
to take a shower and brush my teeth
and get ready to come in here.
I appreciate you doing that by the way.
Keeping up with regular hygiene.
Keeping it fresh.
I mean I'm still shaving and everything.
I'm shaving under my beard
and right on my cheeks
where there's some weird hairs
that grow up above the line.
Oh really?
You wanna have that eyebrow
beard connection happening?
Well Jessie, I don't think
that would ever happen.
But I have a couple of
hairs that are like,
"Should we see if we could
go up higher on the face?"
Yeah, yeah, It's like--
And I'm like, "No, you can't."
Those hairs are like the first ants.
They're like, "Whoa--
They're frontiers men.
It's cooler in here, there's dog food,
I'm gonna excrete some sort of path.
Or maybe they just walk back.
And then, but, my thing is,
if I get every ant that's here
and I corral them all
together and then I spray
and mop them up and throw them
in the trashcan, there's no,
then there's none to go
back and communicate.
But I might just,
I might get them confused with bees
and is it some pheromone
trail that they're dropping?
Because I'm also spraying that.
I think I got it covered,
but my point is I went back upstairs.
I get up, I mosey downstairs,
I drink my coffee.
I do some meditating, do some exercising.
I drink my breakfast.
Then I come back upstairs and I get ready.
Brush my teeth, take a shower.
It was at that point this morning
that I looked on my bathroom counter.
And this is the second floor of my house.
This is, I mean, there's
never any food up here.
You don't do a bedroom eating.
Never, never.
As a policy?
We just don't.
There's never any food
upstairs in our bedroom.
Not like a secret chocolate
stash or anything.
No, no secrets,
you got a secret side of chocolate stash.
Yeah, because I got chocolate in my--
You got night chocolate?
I'm like a middle aged woman
reading a romance novel.
I got dark chocolate bars in
my bedside table because--
Well, you better watch out
'cause the ants are gonna find it.
The kids--
You gotta kid free stash.
Yeah, they'll find the chocolate.
And yes, it is safe for my dog.
I understand that it's deadly to dog,
but Barbara can not get in there and--
She's done open chores.
She's never tried.
I go back up there and then right there
on my kitchen counter where I left it,
like I do every morning is my grinder.
You know what I'm talking about?
Your grinder?
My teeth insert thingy that--
Keeps you from grinding.
Keeps my teeth from grinding--
I would call that a mouth
guard not a grinder--
A mouth guard.
You get confused.
I call it my grinder, 'cause it,
I grind it instead of grinding
my teeth against each other.
Well, it's easy to, say
number of syllables,
and also doesn't lead people
to incorrect conclusions.
Just call it a mouth guard.
You'll seem like Steph Curry.
You know where this is going,
ants all over my grinder.
A bunch of them.
And I'm like, Oh my gosh.
And so I'm rinsing off the mouthpiece
and I'm getting all these ants
go down in the flood of my sink and I'm--
Do feel bad--
And I'm raking them in there.
Do you feel bad in that moment,
that they're all drowning?
No, I'm angry.
I'm like, this has got to stop.
Do you take pleasure in
murdering them though.
No, I guess the thought
does cross my mind.
'Cause I do.
It's like, what are they,
are they feeling, I know
they're not feeling anything.
Christy walks into that moment.
And I was like, "Look at this."
She's like, "God, why are they on that?"
And I'm like, "Cause it's like, I spit."
They wanna eat my spit.
It's different.
They will, ants will congregate around,
it isn't just food sources or sugar.
Sometimes it's electronics.
Like there's something about the vibration
of a certain like--
Based on--
They'll find a walkie talkie
and they'll get on that.
Based on the mouthpiece.
If I lay still enough in my bed,
am I gonna wake up with
a mouth full of ants?
Is that how bad things have got?
You'd probably have to die first?
Or at least be rendered unconscious
for a long period of time.
Also rats can eat your toes
when you're unconscious.
Or your nose.
If you have a rat problem.
So do you have ants crawling
all over your house?
It's funny because we
started noticing ants
earlier in the summer.
And like, we've got the driveway,
that's got like the
white wall on one side.
And so very often as I'm
kind of leaving the drive,
leaving during the morning
or walking up and down the driveway,
there's all kinds of trails
that they will create on that wall--
And you can see it.
And so that's when I'm like,
"Oh, they're active again."
I've tried so many different things.
Oh, excuse me.
For some reason I picked up
a Dr Pepper on the other side
and I'm drinking it.
And the other side--
The other side, you cross
it over and how do we know?
I almost died.
The other side of the
building is what I meant.
But I thought that this year
they were gonna be worse
because I started seeing
them earlier and they,
and one morning Shepherd was like,
"Dad, there's all kinds of
ants in the guest bathroom."
But it hasn't been that bad.
But the thing that we've
noticed is spiders.
Spiders too.
And flies, the other night--
Flies?
Before we got ready to eat dinner,
Jessie had left the door
open for Barbara to go out
and she left it open for too long.
You know what, I have seen
a few flies in my house.
I take that back.
So we're getting ready to eat dinner.
And Jessie's like,
"Could you kill some of those flies?"
'Cause she knows me, I'm the fly assassin.
She knows I take a certain
amount of pride in my work
and you know my technique
slapping above them
and trapping them.
You anticipate their exit--
And exit right into my hand.
And you slap right at that spot.
Now I proceeded to before we eat,
in approximately a 12 minute
period murder seven flies
in my kitchen and there were
still three flying around.
There was a total of 10 that
we found in the kitchen.
Now and Jessie was like,
"What is happening?"
I was like, "It's so hot."
They feel that AC coming
out and they're like,
"Ooh, it's nice in there."
They come in there.
Now--
I bet somebody got a mouthpiece.
To get back to this,
what I began to do and
really upsets my wife.
And I don't quite understand it.
I begin to talk junk to the flies.
And so what I'm doing is I like,
I take a couple of them
out like the fat ones
that are easy and slow.
And then we start getting
down to the nimble ones.
What are the fat ones full of?
Life, I think they've just been around.
I think there's a life cycle.
That would be a mosquito.
I don't know how long flies are alive.
It can't be more than a few weeks.
And I think that those big ass flies
are at the end of their life cycle
and they kind of, they go into,
they go inside somewhere and they get slow
and they become easy targets.
But when it gets down to
those last three or four flies
and they're smaller and
they're more nimble.
I begin to say,
"Hahahaha, you've made it this far.
"You think you're out of the woods.
"You've seen your comrades
go down one by one."
You say this out loud?
Yes. I begin to speak to them.
I think you're, okay.
And I say, "Here's the thing.
"These, my friends are
your last moments on earth.
"Make the most of it."
And Jessie's like, "Please shut up."
She's like, "Don't talk that way.
"It makes me feel bad about the fly."
You're like a--
I'm like, "You're the one
"who asked me to kill them woman."
You're a blood lusting, zealot, despot.
I think it's the fact that
I don't believe in doing harm
to living beings in general
and especially ones
that can like comprehend
the difference between life
and death or pain and not pain.
And it's not just a stimulus.
Let's just say mammals,
you don't like to kill a mammal, right?
Yeah, I do not like to kill a mammal.
No, I don't like the idea
of mammals getting killed.
Yes, I'm a meat eater
Yes, it's hypocritical.
We'll get to that in 10 years.
Okay, but back to--
Mark your calendar.
Don't worry, we'll get to it.
But with flies--
They're an easy target.
It feels like I can take
a little bit of my aggression out.
I mean, everybody's got aggression.
You kind of need to deal with it some way.
And I feel like--
I bite a pillow.
The pillow can't die.
I mean, what happened--
I grind on my grinder.
When I slap the hell out of that fly,
and dies and I throw him in the trash.
I'm like, "I just did something."
I mean that fly was gonna be
alive for another week maybe.
Did you feel better?
Yeah, I do.
But my wife makes me think
a little too much about it.
She's like, "I don't like it
"when you start talking
to them like that."
And I'm like, but I do.
You could just leave the room
and let me talk junk to the flies.
The weird thing is that--
I'm the Lord of the flies.
They don't think about it.
They can't communicate.
And they don't have emotions associated
with being slap murdered.
So the disturbing part
is that you're kind of,
you're putting the things on them
that might deter others
from then killing them.
But you're like,
you're slathering that on them.
Hey, feel this, think about
what I'm about to do to you.
I'm talking to them
like I'm killing humans.
Because it seems more substantial.
That's why it's troubling.
Let me just, okay.
I'm gonna tell you--
And I'm on Jessie side.
Okay, can I take,
one additional little tangent,
you're gonna,
I don't know what you're
gonna think about this idea,
but last night we were watching
the most recent season of--
If you're gonna say that
you then eat the fly.
I don't wanna hear it.
Last night we were, I'm just trying,
this is my mind I'm open--
Is this another reality TV?
I'm opening my mind and my
heart to you and to you.
And I know being vulnerable
can get you in trouble,
but I'm going for it, okay.
So I was watching the latest season
of Married at First Sight, with Jessie.
And I don't like the people this season.
I like them less than I didn't
like the people last season
or hate them more than
I hated the people last,
I actually started
liking some of the people
in the previous season,
but I don't like any of these couples yet.
And there's five couples for
the first time ever five.
So you're talking about killing them.
What?
No, what I told Jessie as I was like,
what do you think in the future?
I think there might be a feature
where you get so upset
with the characters on a reality show
that you can like press a command into the
device that you're watching.
And they'll like die on screen
just for your own personal satisfaction.
And they won't be a part
of the show anymore.
That level of interaction,
but they don't really die.
It's just like a sh,
it's first like a first person shooter.
But it's the show that you're watching.
You're like, "I hate
that character so much."
Or I hate this couple
and you press a button
and they both go and they
fall down and die on the show.
And I was like, I know this demented,
but I hate this one couple in particular.
He cringed, made me cringe so
hard that I wanna hurt them.
And I know that's wrong.
But if I see it as just the
thing that's happening in media,
like in video games and it's not real,
it's all just portrayed and acted.
It feels like it would be okay,
Bring this to your therapist.
And then once.
But what do you think about that feature?
It could, maybe it's just,
you could tickle the characters.
Logistically it doesn't work.
No, but in the future
they can do anything.
If it was like on a touch screen--
You're not the only one watching a show,
is what I'm saying.
But your feed is your feed
and you tickle the person.
They laugh on your feed.
It's interactive, it's personalized.
And you poke them hard enough?
It's like a voodoo doll and they get hurt.
So you want to have
personalized VR, basically it's
well, it's a personalized reality show.
Yeah, that I can interact with.
It's like a video game.
It's a video game, yes.
It's a video game, but
it's a reality show.
I think this is gonna happen.
But where you were just going with the VR,
I think a VR game in
which you're in a kitchen
and you're killing flies
with your two VR hands.
That's just a phone app.
Well, I guess, no--
You gotta be VR.
You gotta have that.
I'm gonna make that game.
Fly, fly, assassin, fly Assassin's creed.
I'm gonna jump on that train.
I don't kill any flies in my house
'cause Jade kills them.
That's the only reason she gets--
Jade kills flies?
She's seven inches tall.
Does she kill the ones that are above her?
She waits for them to come
down and they always do.
And she kills them?
Yeah, she bites them
and then they're on the
ground and she sniffs them.
And I think she eats when I'm not looking.
How reliable is she?
'Cause if we could work together--
I'll rent her out to you.
I'll go for the high,
she'll go for the low.
Yeah, yeah, that could be--
No fly is gonna escape us.
You'd be an exterminating doggy man duo.
We're gonna talk about board games,
but we do want to remind
you, if you watched GMM,
you know about this
already, votelikeabeast.com.
This is a website that we put together
because we are really trying to motivate
people to take part in
the election this year.
Yeah, I've, you know it's,
I remember back
when we were at Buies
Creek Elementary School,
I guess we were in eighth grade.
It was the Clinton,
it was when Clinton won
the presidential election.
92 that would have been--
So Clinton Bush--
Had been a freshman year.
Was it?
Who did he run against?
It was Bush going for a second term.
Yeah, yeah, the first Bush.
Herbert Walker.
And I remember being really into that.
Like all the kids in the school voted--
In school-wide election.
School-wide election,
it was very exciting.
And I don't remember being
in that heated either.
It was just fun.
You know, it's like, this is not fun,
but for the first time
since that election,
I actually feel like, "Oh
my gosh this matters."
Now of course I've voted--
For the first time since 92.
This is Lincoln not been
really been paying attention.
I mean, you know that elections matter.
But it's very palpable
to me this time around.
And there's just a level of urgency
that I haven't felt before--
Well, I think a lot of people
will say that because--
And I don't think that's
true, but that is--
No, no, no, I think, no,
think about how much political discourse--
Let me clarify what I think was true.
I think all elections
are extremely important.
That's what I mean.
But there is something about this election
for me personally, that
I'm the most engaged
I've ever been--
And I think you speak for a lot of people.
What I'm getting at
is the reason you speak for
a lot of people is because
many people who didn't
care at all about politics.
And I'm not saying you didn't
care all about politics,
but you're not really a
politically motivated person.
But a lot of people who were in that boat
have seen what's happened in our country
over the past four years.
Think about how much we talk
about the President in a way
that we've never talked about a president.
The news is so dominated
by political discourse.
We're even more polarized
than we were four years ago.
And so a lot of people are like,
"Ah, I guess I'm gonna be
a part of this process."
And we still the same thing.
And on Good Mythical Morning,
there are certain, we don't
get political on the show
by and large, it's like we
try to preserve that space
to be an escape from, I don't know--
You get that in certain places.
Like if you find yourself witnessing
or being a part of like a Twitter war
or some sort of ugly back
and forth on Facebook,
we don't wanna bring that
into Good Mythical Morning.
I don't wanna bring
that type of energy
into my life personally,
but we did want to do something
to mobilize everyone to vote.
And to help make the
each person's decision,
to enable their decision
as much as possible,
whatever their decision may be--
Voting Like a Beast goes beyond
the really important first step,
which is just registering to
vote and being ready to vote,
which is important.
So you can do that at Vote Like a Beast.
But the sort of the next layer
that we think is important
is informing yourself.
Because you, as a citizen
who is eligible to vote,
the most clear way that you can actually
let your voice be heard,
according to the issues
that you find important
is by exercising your right to vote.
And a lot of times people are just like,
"Oh, my vote really doesn't count.
"It kinda gets lost in the mix."
But the collective power of our voices
is incredibly important.
The collective power of the vote
consists of individual voters like you.
And when you can make
the connection between
what you believe and what
you find to be important
and what you would like to
see happen in your country,
to the candidates who have policies
that they've laid out publicly,
that makes you an informed voter.
So that do we have tools on the site
that help make those connections.
Profiles of candidates.
We link out to resources
that we've kind of
brought together aggregated into one place
to make you have the option
of being an informed voter
to the point where you can
actually take a voter guide
into the ballot box, if
you're voting in person,
or you can have it right there
when you're voting by mail.
So you can make choices that
are according to your interests
and how you are informed about the issues.
So it's all in one place.
We try to make it as simple as possible
to empower you to vote
according to your conscience,
that's votelikeabeast.com.
We invite you to check it out
and share that with people.
It's nonpartisan, go for it.
Vote.
Like a Beast.
Let's talk about the
shirt that you're wearing.
Have you joined a softball team?
No.
Have you ever thought about it?
I'm open to anything now that
involves like getting out
and like playing with people,
whenever the time comes
that I can do that again.
Okay, softball it is.
So it might be softball
and I've got the shirt,
the Mythical softball team, join up now.
You also can get a pinot, mythical.com.
I think it's technically
the baseball team,
but you know what, the rules
are is almost exactly the same.
The balls are bigger.
Balls are bigger.
And listen, you can pick a
bigger ball, always do that.
Softball over baseball, mythical.com.
Mythical.com, rep you
boys when you're out there
on the diamond and bring
the diamond with you
wherever you go.
Okay, so let's get into board games.
I wanted to talk about this
'cause I'm on a journey.
Okay, I know we're all on a journey,
but I'd like to think that
I am on a very specific and special.
Everybody thinks their journey
is the most important one.
That's what makes you human.
And I've come to an intersection
that involves board games.
We talked about our vacations,
a few episodes back.
And the one thing that I kept from you,
because it was so special to my heart.
I just didn't know if I wanted to share.
Was, well, really we ran out of time.
'Cause I think we ended up talking about
probably reality TV.
Yeah, I'm sure it was.
We are not a board game playing family,
but Christy packed these board games.
I didn't even know we had.
And I'm like, you know what?
I saw a couple of board games.
And the first one that we
ended up playing was Codenames.
And the reason why is
because we play Codenames,
I learned Codenames at your house
in your monthly game night,
which is currently on COVID hiatus.
And I was like, you know what?
This isn't a, I would not
call that a board game.
I call it a party game.
But I think I'm, I don't
have the terminology right,
'cause I'm just beginning of my--
There is as a board though.
There is a board.
For those of you don't
know how Codenames works.
Well, I can't explain it.
It's a verbal game where
you're divided into two teams.
So with our family, it was
Gracie was there with us.
And so it was three against three.
And I think she brought this game action.
I was like, "Oh, I love this game."
Because it's not a strategy game.
It's a verbal game where
you're like giving clues,
I'll try to quickly explain the rules.
And it probably won't
mean anything to you.
So I'll make it quick.
But basically you have
a board in front of you
that has a series of words on it.
You put cards down and
it's one word per card.
And they're in a mosaic.
And you are trying to get your team
to guess the words that are
associated with your team
and not guess the words that
are associated with the other team.
And the more that,
and you can only give one word clues.
And so you're trying to come up with,
when it's your turn,
and basically you have one
person who is the clue giver
for that round for the team.
And you're trying to come up with one word
that will connect as many of those words
on the board that are your words.
So if it was like--
Saturn, space and telescope,
you might say astronomy,
but if you had Saturn and space
and you and I are the clue
givers for our opposite teams,
I also know which words are yours.
And if I had Venus--
Venus was yours, I can't, I
could say three astronomy.
And that means three of
the words on the board
could be associated with astronomy.
And then everyone on my
team, verbally processes
and it's kind of torturous to
then give the clue and listen.
But it's very fun.
I believe it to be.
It's a great, great game.
I believe it to be the best.
It is the best game that we
have played at game night.
Yeah, it's good for a party.
There's not a lot of strategy involved.
There's a lot of interplay
between all the players.
So we started playing that--
There's Codenames pictures as well,
which is the same thing but--
Oh, a sequel.
You ever played that,
I thought it as well.
I've never played that.
It's the same exact thing,
except it's pictures instead of words.
The rules are exactly the same.
And what you're trying to,
in the way you're giving
clues is exactly the same,
but you're trying to get
them to guess these pictures.
And it's weird because it will be like
these weird symbolic sort of
mosaic type symbol pictures that--
Are open to interpretation.
Open to interpretation.
So you have to find what your partner
and your team is thinking.
And that's great.
We were having a lot
of fun and it was like,
"Oh my gosh,
"this is exactly what I
hoped our vacation will be."
Our family has gathered around a table.
We're playing a game together
and everybody's happy.
Well, we don't own Codenames.
Break up the board games.
We don't own Codenames.
And yeah, because I've
never enjoyed board games.
I'll get into that more.
But then there were two
nights of playing Codenames
and boy, every--
Everybody was into it.
There was food, there was drink.
There was music, there was Codenames.
There was togetherness.
Alcohol for the whole family.
The whole family.
Jade was drunk off heart.
Very AS.
And then I'm looking over there
and I'd seen this other game.
And I was like Catan, or is it Katon?
I think Katon is the
correct pronunciation,
but Catan is what--
I was like, this is Settlers of Catan.
I didn't know we own this.
And it was a brand new game.
Was it junior or irregular?
Regular, Christy had bought this thing.
And so the third morning after
the two nights of Codenames,
I'm like, you know what,
I'm gonna open this up.
Never been played, fresh out of the box.
I was reading about it.
I was like, we're going to do this.
We're going to do this.
Now I had heard about this game
and I'm like, this is not gonna be for me.
This is a strategy game.
I've always hated strategy.
I've never had a good
experience with a strategy game.
And again, we'll get, we can,
I'm curious about your
past and your perspective,
which I think is different than mine,
but we can go into the reasons why,
but I'm like, you know what,
It was such a good experience.
I want this quintessential
strategy board game
and we should give it a shot.
It's an intricate board.
We got punch,
we got to pull everything out
and set it up for the first time.
Lando, even if he can't follow the game
because he's 10 years old,
he'll enjoy setting it up.
Well, actually he did
enjoy playing the game
and followed just like anybody else.
So he was as good as me.
And we had a great experience playing
what I would call Settlers of Catan.
But the box just says, Catan,
How long did it take?
Because we were learning
and they do a really good job of like,
if you're just learning,
you kinda skip ahead a little bit.
They kinda prime the game
a little bit for you.
So you have the momentum of the beginning.
Have you ever played it?
Yeah.
I had never, ever played it.
I'd only heard of it.
And I think we,
it was like an hour and a
half, maybe almost two hours.
And I loved it.
The reason why I loved it was 'cause,
I mean, you're like,
you trade with people in order to like,
to settle this land called Catan.
We settled on it being Catan.
In the Neil house, we call it Catan.
I think that's fine.
I think that might be right, I don't know.
You build roads, you build settlements
and then you turn them
into cities and then it,
you have to do it by like
trading and sheep for brick.
And you're trading with people
and there's some strategy
involved, but it's not too crazy.
I mean, I, we were,
just as a flashback,
when Christy and I were first married
before we started having kids.
We were invited to, we had
these friends, an older couple.
They had some kids who
were like middle-schoolers
and they said,
"We want you to come over
and play Risk with us."
And it was like the
worst night of my life.
They were so into it.
I didn't know how to play.
And I just don't,
at that night, I concluded, you know what?
I don't, I can't get this,
it's very frustrating.
It lasts forever.
I just don't have a mind for strategy.
I don't have a strategy
mind, you know what,
it's my shortcoming, I'm
not gonna blame it on them,
but they are really into it.
And it's a little bit alienating.
And why has this taking forever?
Let's just talk.
Risk is his own is his own thing.
We used to--
So just to complete my thought,
I thought I would hate,
I was like really proud of myself,
because here I am doing a strategy game
and it seems like everybody's involved.
And I'm like, I'm actually following this.
Turns out when I looked
online to find other games
like Catan, that we could also play,
it's categorized as a light strategy game.
So that kinda--
Yeah, there's not a lot to it.
That's knocked down my ego a little bit.
I think it's fun.
Now, speaking of Risk, because,
we used to play,
like me and my father-in-law,
my brother-in-law
and like an assorted bunch
whoever happened to be around.
Sometimes it was my wife's
cousin that was there as well,
when they were in town.
Would play these really
intense, long games of Risk.
And the thing about Risk is,
the games can last for hours.
It's not, I mean, we would sometimes go in
and just like three or
four hour long games.
'Cause it kept going back and forth
and everyone who was playing,
like you think I'm competitive.
I was easily the least
competitive in this group,
between my father-in-law
and my brother-in-law
and my wife's cousin.
As long as everybody's
into it, that's great.
No, but what would happen is,
and this is why I wanna get
back to asking you about,
'cause this maps onto like,
the way my family plays games,
it would get my father-in-law
and my brother-in-law,
would sometimes, I was like,
"They're gonna fight,
they're finally gonna fight."
You know what I'm saying?
Like fist fight.
'Cause it was so intense.
It would get so intense.
And like you do these
things that like with Risk,
you have the option of like,
I'm gonna team up with this guy
and we're gonna sabotage you
and we're gonna take you out.
And a lot of times we would
do that to my father-in-law,
because he was the best at the game.
He's been playing for a long time,
you know how he's so competitive.
And so--
That made,
nothing makes you angry than
if you get teamed up against him,
there's nothing, there's
little you can do.
And I was always just kinda like,
a little bit like Switzerland.
I didn't start in Switzerland,
that's not a great strategy.
But I'm really competitive,
but I would just kinda play it.
I was just like,
"This is entertaining because
"they're so passionate about this."
And if you go to somebody who's like,
they've got their strategy down.
You can't just, like that couple,
did you a disservice by
inviting you into a game
that can be as intense as Risk
and not like picking up on your signals
that you were not into it
or that maybe we should like
play it in a more inviting way.
It reminds me of the story of when we,
back in 19, oh not,
it was 2003 probably,
when we were on our staff training
to go on staff with Campus Crusade.
Yeah, we went down to Florida.
So we were there like taking
seminary classes for a summer.
And then also being trained
in like everything we were gonna do.
And we became really good friends
with Eric and Natalie
who were from Tennessee
and the six of us really got along.
We're all basically newlyweds I would say.
We were newlyweds and, and we just,
we all liked each other.
And so we connected with them
probably more than
anybody at staff training.
And we got into playing, not a board game,
but a game, party game Catch Phrase.
And the reason why we played that,
'cause by that point,
again that was around the same
time as the Risk incident.
And like in college, we
would play Risks some.
Like there were people who liked Risk.
And now I was like by the,
I was became convinced that
like, none of this was for me,
none of these board games, strategy games,
but party games like Catch
Phrase where it's like,
it's quick and it's verbal and it's fun.
And then it's over.
And you can basically end
it any time, it's not this,
like you don't have to
invest the whole night in it.
And then if it goes sideways
or somebody gets upset.
The learning curve is much lower.
It's simple.
You sit down and you get it.
And then, but we--
I was very into,
and still am very into
something like Catch Phrase.
And we say this all the time,
you don't think you're competitive.
I think you're just as competitive as me.
You just show it in a different way.
But I think you hate to
lose just as much as me,
you're just better at
keeping it to yourself.
Now, and you would get super, super into--
I don't know about that
but we can come back to it.
So we would start playing this,
the six of us and we would
get so into it, like loud.
We were at the, what was it?
The El Caribe, was that
the hotel that we were in--
It was like an apartment building.
I mean, everyone,
do we need to explain
what Catch Phrase is?
Basically, it's hot potato, but like you,
it's like password.
There's a word you've
gotta get people to guess.
And you can't say the word.
And if it stops in your hands you lose.
So we, there was this other couple
that we didn't really know that well,
but they were on,
they were gonna go on staff
with athletes and action,
which is the Campus Crusade
wing that ministers to athletes.
Yeah, they were like--
They had been college athletes.
And so we were like, these
people are competitive.
They surely will be
into how wild and crazy
and intense our games of Catch Phrase get.
We invited them over one night.
And we're playing the game
and we're doing our typical like yelling.
And like when somebody gets
it wrong everybody yells,
when somebody gets it
right everybody yells.
And I'm just kinda
noticing this couple is--
Shrinking.
They're not really being loud at all.
They're not, they don't seem
like they have the will to win.
And I think we scarred them forever.
They did not ask to come back
and we didn't talk a whole lot after.
I think that the energy
we had, it was like,
it was just, it was fun to have energy.
We were playing guys against girls.
And I think, one of the
things that happens with me
when I'm playing a game is I get,
I'll say things like, is he mad?
He seems mad?
And if you're the kind of person
who that kind of inner--
Comedic effect--
That kind of energy.
If he knew you.
Well, no, I'm just,
I'm really getting into it.
But the moment that like,
we got to order a pizza.
I'm like, what y'all want on the pizza?
You know what I'm saying, it's
like, I'm not actually mad.
I'm just really intensely competing.
It's like, when you're playing
basketball with somebody
and you're like talking trash to them,
but then you're like,
"Hey, let's leave in the same car."
It's just part of the
competitive spirit for me.
But some people don't
respond well to that.
And they think,
"Oh, these people must
be mad at each other."
And I think that, that wasn't how they're,
they were also newlyweds.
I don't think that's
how it worked for them.
Whereas in our marriages,
I feel like there was a lot of like,
you could be loud with your spouse
and it didn't mean you were mad with them.
I mean, that's definitely how
me and Jessie are, you know.
I think also when you
and I were on a team,
we could give clues
that seemed impossible.
'Cause we knew how we were doing--
It's like we would speak in code
and then it would be very frustrating--
We were tough to beat.
We we're tough to beat when
we're on the same team.
Yes, that was very,
that was hilarious to us
and very decimating and frustrating too.
But so when you're playing--
To competitors--
Catan as a family--
They ended up just not coming around.
Right, so when you're playing
Catan as a family, are you,
it sounds to me, what I
was picturing in my mind,
as you were talking about
it, isn't like, this is,
I want to win.
And that's the main
thing I'm thinking about.
It was more, I'm having a
great time with my family.
That's what I was feeling.
Lincoln is pretty competitive
and he's a very strategic thinker.
I don't get that
competitive directly with,
I mean, I get competitive
for the sake of like entertaining
myself and my family,
but like not in the same way that,
on game night, like I want to win.
And it becomes personal.
With my family it's like,
if Shepherd wins this game,
that's awesome for him.
So I'm not gonna try to like take him out.
Well, I actually won.
But I wasn't like gloating or anything.
I was actually surprised.
'Cause I, Lincoln started,
he built all of his
cities in this one place
where like with,
odds are he would end up
getting all these bricks.
He became, he was talking
all this smack about,
hey, he was a brick factory.
"Oh, I got so much brick.
"If anybody wants any brick,
you gotta come to me."
That became fun, when it was just like,
you start to play a role
in the game of like,
you're the brick mogul
and then people think
he's doing so well 'cause
he's got so much brick
that nobody wants to trade with him.
And then he gets frustrated
and that was fun.
Fun to watch people get frustrated.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We were all doing the same
thing and having a good time,
so then I'm coming, I'm
like, this is a new,
this is a new era.
I think we can do this.
At the beginning of
quarantine, I was thinking,
you know what, it's puzzle
time, it's game time.
And on the Mythical Society,
we were doing this thing early on
where all the Mythical crew members
were making videos from home about
like what they were
doing during quarantine
and making suggestions about things
that you could also enjoy while
being isolated in quarantine
and Caleb, our Graphic Designer,
who give him credit for most,
all of the merch stuff that's designed.
He does the vast majority of that.
I happen to be watching one
of his videos on the Society.
And he started talking about board games
and he talked about this
one game called PARKS.
And the way he talked about
it was a strategy game
where you go through,
when you make your way through
all the national parks.
And I'm like, "My dream is to like,
"be the dad who goes to
all the national parks
"with my family."
While never leaving my living room.
So now we can do that here.
And it's like, the
artwork look really cool.
And then it was, ended
up I couldn't get one.
I had to, they have a Kickstarter
campaign for an expansion.
And I ordered that.
I still haven't gotten it, but I was like,
"You know what, we're
gonna get this PARKS game.
"And this is gonna be
the new family thing."
Hasn't happened, but I do,
that's the next thing I'm excited about.
We come back from the beach and I'm like,
"All right, every Sunday
that's gonna be our game time."
And so, you know me, I'm
like, I'm excited about Catan.
That's what we're gonna play.
And I thought everybody
else would be excited.
This is the new Neil
thing, tabletop gaming.
And then Lily is like, "I
don't want to play that,
"that game stupid."
I was like, it wasn't stupid two days ago.
She was like "Shape and
bricks, it's not for me."
You ran into a teenage mentality.
I'm like, you just made me so mad.
I was like, well, we're gonna play a game.
And we ended up playing the star,
we had a Star Wars version
of clue, which that,
we didn't even finish.
I was like, look at what happened.
Fizzle out.
Fizzle out, and then Lincoln's a few,
the next weekend Lincoln's
like, "We should play among us."
I'm like "Tabletop game."
He was like, "No, we each
need to be on our phones.
"It's a video game on
your phone that you play.
"It's fun with five people,
"but you can't talk to each other.
"And even though we're in the same room,
"you gotta act like we're
like in different rooms."
Wow, okay, yeah.
And I'm like, seriously, I was,
I told Lily, I was like, if we play Clue,
next time we are gonna go back to Catan,
and we're gonna like it.
We are going to like it.
That's the dad spirit.
And then we didn't get back,
now we're playing among us,
which is actually a pretty,
it's a very fun game--
Is it one of those games where like,
you're all looking at the television,
like those trivia games
that are on your phone?
You're all looking at
this spaceship schematic.
And you're running around
and you're a crew member,
but then one person is an imposter
and he's sabotaging everything on the ship
and killing people.
And then you have to, if
you're a crew member and again,
every time you play the game,
you're randomly assigned.
You have to perform tasks
to like run around the ship
and do things.
But if you're the imposter,
you have to act like you're doing things.
But then when you're along with somebody,
you have to kill him.
And then when you,
when a crew member finds someone dead,
they have to report dead body.
And then everybody comes
together and you discuss,
like, you actually can talk at that point
about who you think the imposter is.
So it's got like a mafia
werewolf kind of vibe, I think.
But it's mostly in this gaming world.
Of course I'm so freaking oblivious
to how to play a video game.
That they're just laughing
at me the whole time.
And then ultimately getting angry at me
because I don't know what
a dead body looks like.
I don't know how to move around.
They're like, he was standing
still for a really long time.
He must have been, he must be the killer.
No, I don't know how to move.
It's like, I don't know how to move.
Yeah, I got stuck.
So we quickly moved.
Somehow my family has taken
us away from our new identity
as a board gaming family back
into like our own phone zone.
Well, but I think this is still a victory
to be celebrated because first of all,
the distinction between
board games and party games
is one that--
And video games, blurring,
No, I'm just saying that when it comes to
what it is that you're
trying to accomplish,
which is doing something,
I'm not gonna say not on screens
because that is on screen,
but doing something together,
that's fun as a family,
creating family memories,
the distinction between the
board games and party games.
It doesn't matter.
I was happy that most everybody
was willing to play that
game at least three times
until it was like, somebody was like,
I don't wanna do this anymore.
I going to my room,
you can't go to your room.
The thing that you're always dealing with
when it comes to teenagers
is them being on their phones
and then being in contact
with their friends, girlfriends,
whatever, the people that
they stay in contact with.
Their attention spans are really short.
And it's very difficult for them to unplug
from being in contact.
And also just their attention
spans are short in general.
I mean, we watch a lot of movies
and I try to introduce the kids
to movies that I grew up with and,
Locke and I watch horror movies together.
And now we've kinda gotten,
you know he's 16 now
and now we're watching some
of the movies from my list
of my favorite movies that
I wouldn't let him watch up until now.
And when you get, when you're looking at
a total running time of like
two and a half, three hours,
for some of these movies,
that is a lifetime for
a teenager these days-
Yeah, I told my kids, I'm like,
you don't know how to watch a movie.
You can't do it.
You can watch a show--
Well, but what they'll do is
they will binge a television show
and they'll sit down for five or six hours
and watch a whole season
of a television show.
But the feeling of them
having some sort of control
of them being able to like
take a break between episodes,
because it's naturally broken up that,
I mean, that's why in theory I know Quibi
had had a really bad launch,
but like something like Quibi
made a lot of sense on paper
because it was, a it
was designed for mobile.
I watched a couple of shows on there
and like the whole like
flipping to vertical
and the way that that
actually changed the interact,
it changed it in a way that was cooler
than I expected it to be.
But also the fact that,
depending on the show,
it's like, this is broken
up into byte sized pieces,
but it's telling a longer story.
I mean, I didn't get
into any of the content,
but only tried a couple of things.
But in theory it made sense.
It's like, let's go mobile.
Let's have a bias towards vertical.
Let's make it into byte sized pieces
that I don't understand, it just,
they got a bunch of great
talent to be in the shows
and to make the shows,
all that to say is what
I've observed is that
the thing that you're battling
is the teenager attention span.
And so board games fit right into that.
I can't even get a kid
to watch a movie with me.
We just what, I was just like,
I'll say, "Hey, let's watch a movie."
And they're like, eh.
I'm like, "Okay, well let's watch a show."
They're like, all right.
Well, and it's like, Locke will--
It's like they'll commit
to like 40 minutes
or 60 minutes with me.
And I take it personally, it's like,
that's all you can take of me.
And once that's over, it's like
"I'm gonna go back in my room."
In order to watch
something else without me.
But the thing that Locke will do
is he and his friends
will, there'll be, he like,
he texted me the other
night is with a friend.
And he was like, "Dad, what
was the name of that movie
"that we watched where
this and that happened?"
I was like, send him the text.
I was like, it was this.
And then I pick him up
and he's like, I'm like,
"Hey, did you watch a
movie, did you enjoy it?"
He says, "Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah."
I mean, I ask him about a part.
He's like, "We didn't finish it."
Didn't finish.
"We didn't finish it."
I'm like, "What you
didn't finish the movie."
I don't understand how
the teenage brain works.
And it wasn't because, it was just like,
the night was over or whatever.
And it's like, "We'll watch
the rest of it later."
It's like I,
again in theory, the
Quibi thing makes sense.
It seems like it was the answer to that,
but it just didn't,
it hasn't worked yet.
I feel like it still will
at some point, I don't know.
Whoa, just, hey I gotta go down.
We've been rewatching,
and this is Lily's idea,
rewatching all the Marvel movies.
She's a huge Marvel fan.
And I was like, "This is
good, I like a game plan."
The Niels are watching
all the Marvel movies.
We went through all the Lord of the Rings
and we're watching Survivor
and we're watching the Lord of
the Rings behind the scenes.
Like we have different things
that are ongoing and I,
that is an appeal of series.
And then she kind of applied
that to Marvel movies.
So then it's like, we're
gonna watch all of these.
She's so into them.
But I'm like, girl, you gotta,
graduate is not the right word.
But it is what I kind of feel like.
I'm a huge fan of all the Marvel movies.
I love watching them,
but there's something,
you gotta watch like good movies too.
It's not what you would
call classic cinema.
Yeah, cinematically to some more
artistic approaches to things.
Yeah, well, and I feel
like I broke that seal.
I told you that Locke and
I watched Pulp Fiction.
It was like, he kept leaning over,
'cause I remember I watched
it when we were in college.
And we remember, we talked
about this on the show
when we talked about our favorite movies.
And the way it like transformed
what we thought was possible with a movie.
So was he into it?
He kept turning to me
and he was just like,
God, see, like making those faces
and saying these things
like this is so great.
Like the very beginning
when they're having
that conversation about
the Royale with cheese,
like he just got this smile on his face.
I was like, yes, he
understands why this is good.
And since then he's,
we've been watching a bunch of movies
and from that time in my life.
But still even when, Friday night,
Saturday night rolls
around and he's at home.
He don't want to be with you
on a couch for three hours.
Yeah, even though I've introduced him
to these great movies.
It still is this thing that's like, it's,
there's the threshold to overcome
to get them to be like,
"Yeah, I wanna sit down and
devote my evening to this."
It's a lot.
It's a lot that they would--
I was like, let's watch a movie.
You know what, tonight
we're gonna watch a movie.
We're going to watch a movie.
Lando is not here.
Lando was at your house
for Shepherd's birthday.
Just the two of them.
And they watched a movie.
And I was like, we can watch a movie
that Lando can't watch.
We're gonna watch The Reverent.
Leonardo DiCaprio is--
That's one on the list for me--
Is amazing, this one, and
they were a little reticent,
but I'm like, this is happening.
It's a good movie, you're gonna like it.
It's not too long into it
that there's the bear attack.
And Lily like stands up.
And I honestly, I had
forgotten how traumatic,
I mean, how real this and relentless.
I mean, I wouldn't call it a bear attack.
I would call it three bear attacks.
I don't know if you remember,
we saw it in the theater.
And that was the only time I'd seen it.
The bear attacks at the
dude three different times.
And after the first time
you're like, "Oh my gosh,
"I just don't feel like
I can keep watching this.
"I don't know if I can take this.
"This is so intense."
And so Lily is like, "I can't watch this."
And you know what?
She was like--
Like sit down and watch
this guy get maimed.
Yeah, I was like, well, listen,
but I was like, you loved Us,
like you watch all these,
you watch stuff that's just as intense.
Like there was, I mean,
that was real and scary,
but yeah, it was--
And gory.
And gory, but so was Us,
Us was in very scary and very gory.
Us is gory.
She's like, turns out it
was the intensity of it,
but it was also, I didn't,
and she's inching our way to the door now.
And she's like, I just
don't wanna watch two guys
chase themselves around,
chase around each other on the wilderness.
Chase themselves around the wilderness.
I can't even put the sentence together,
but you know what I'm saying?
Chase went on wilderness.
I'm like, well, I'm losing this battle.
But then Christy and
Lincoln watched it with me.
And I think Lincoln was like
"That was a good movie."
He watched the whole thing.
We watched the whole thing.
It's a long movie.
It's a good movie cinematically, I mean--
We wanna watch that one together.
Pretty mind blowing,
but it's very intense.
To get to get back to games for a second.
We're gonna play Catan again this weekend.
I'm getting back on that horse.
Now you talked about
how you didn't think you
would be into strategy games.
Now for the longest time,
I've always just thought,
man, it makes sense that you
would be into strategy games
and board games because there's
rules and there's a system.
And like, once you
learn it and execute it,
there are specific results.
It seems to tie into your
oneness on the inner gram.
I've not had a lot of experience.
And I think I was thrown in the deep end.
I have never played monopoly.
I've never played it.
We have that as a--
I told Lily that, and Lily
was like, dad, who are you?
I mean, how does this happen?
I'm like, I was an only child.
Like I didn't play, I didn't a family.
I had a mom, like me and mom
aren't gonna sit down and play monopoly.
You can't play with just two people.
This is what is always
perplexing to me in, is that--
And I didn't watch movies with my mom.
Most of the time--
I was just--
No, but I didn't.
Here's the thing, played
monopoly as a kid.
But my family did not play board games.
Who did you play monopoly with?
It would just be like, in the time between
I was zero and 18.
And somewhere in childhood, it'd be like,
you're at someone's home
or you're at like your cousin's house
or somebody has monopoly and you play it.
My kids have played it.
I didn't seek these things out.
They sought me out.
I feel like you were
purposely avoiding them.
It has to be--
There was an opportunity
and you were like,
"Ah, that's not for me."
Has to be.
I think I was in, anything strategy,
you're taking a long time.
I think it was how my
kids feel about movies.
I felt about these games.
It's like, you gotta learn a lot.
You gotta like think hard
and you can't let up.
Like, it just seems exhausting.
I'll played Connect Four.
And listen, the McLaughlin's,
the issue with the McLaughlin's
is attention span and also
adhering to a system or rules.
It's very difficult because I am by far
the most system oriented
person in my family.
And on the spectrum of people,
I'm somewhere in the middle probably
in terms of like how much
system there is in my life.
But in my family I'm on the extreme.
And so like rules and systems
and having to do things in a certain way,
mixed with really competitive
people who don't like to lose
all of us, all four of us is a,
it can make for an incredible time
or it can make for like an,
somebody is gonna cry,
there's gonna be some
explosiveness that happens.
I've seen it on Shepherd's
face a number of times,
when you're the youngest one
and you're the youngest one by five years,
up until pretty recently, it was like,
he just doesn't have the
faculties to be super competitive
in some of these games.
Whatever we might be playing.
And so you could see that,
like when he makes a mistake
that, "Oh, there it is.
"He just lost the game."
He just made a critical mistake,
he'd get this look on his
face like I've blown it.
You know what I'm saying.
He's like, he wants to win so bad.
And it's just like, it's
only, and this is a flaw.
This is something that I've had to,
I continue to work on is
like, are you having fun
if you don't win.
Super competitive people
have trouble having fun
if they don't,
if they're not winning.
If they're doing something
and they're like,
I'm not good at this.
And I don't think I'm gonna
be able to be good enough
at this to be competitive in it.
So I'm gonna lose interest.
And so those are the kind of factors,
but I think the fact that
everybody wants to win ultimately
is how you get people roped
into games in my family.
But we started quarantine with games
and they've completely fallen off.
Like we were playing Scrabble.
I mean, we were scrabbling it up.
I've never played Scrabble.
Again, that's odd to me,
that you haven't run across a Scrabble.
There's a Scrabble board
somewhere on the street
that you just found yourself playing on.
I got it, I mean like grandparents,
wouldn't never played games.
Like I don't recall, I mean, as you and I,
we would never play games.
Well, like I said,
we didn't have games
in my house growing up.
We didn't have Scrabble.
I played Scrabble probably the first time
as an adult because
Jessie's parents had it.
And they let us sit down and play Scrabble
and I'm like, all right, I know words.
Apparently not nearly
as many as Jessie's mom.
I don't think that I am,
it's not really about,
am I competitive or not?
There's also a second
factor along with that.
That's like the group dynamic.
Yeah, trying to set
the scene for a family.
Well, what I'm saying?
Yes, I think I'm most
interested in that with family,
my family and none of
us are that competitive.
Like nobody gets that upset
about winning or losing
or anything and at least at this point,
maybe we'll get more competitive,
but we'll be on that journey together.
I think that I was turned
off by being in environments
where people were a lot more competitive
and then you just start to feel stupid.
It's kind of embarrassing.
Like it's a bad feeling
when people know how to play something,
like Shepherd's experience.
I think that was part of my experience.
I'm like, ah, I don't want to have that.
I don't wanna look like a
dummy in front of everybody
who's played monopoly their whole life.
So it's like, I'm not, so,
and then that might come
out as I'm not competitive.
So again, I can't even
tell, like I actually don't.
Well, there is a difference
because with Shepherd,
what he'll want to do is he'll wanna play,
let's start over or let's
play tomorrow night.
So he doesn't be like,
"Okay, I don't want to play
this game again 'cause I lost."
He's like, "I wanna play this
game again because I lost."
But I don't think,
I'm trying to set the stage for,
I actually don't think I'm competitive.
You think I'm competitive,
I think I don't.
I think there's something
that you're interpreting
as I'm deep down competitive,
but I think I'm interested
in something different.
Like not looking stupid.
I think when the stage is
set, and we're doing something
that you feel confident
in, like, you're like,
I understand this game and
I have reason to believe
that I am just as good
or better at the people
that I'm playing against.
I think when the setting is right,
when the circumstances are right,
you want to win as much as I want to win.
I think the difference is that
if I enter a situation and
I'm not good at something,
I have to really resist the urge
to like, okay, with
poker, for instance, like,
I started playing poker with
my wife's family long time ago,
like early in our marriage.
And like, it got
competitive really quickly.
And I'm like,
if I'm going to have a
chance of winning at this
I gotta understand it.
So I went and got all
these books about poker
and like read all these
strategy about poker,
because it was, instead
of like, you know what,
when you guys play poker,
I'm not gonna be a part of it,
which is what you might do.
I'm just like, which was
probably ultimately more healthy.
'Cause I'm just wasting time
learning how to play poker.
In one sentence I'm not gonna be like
a professional poker player,
but then I'm like,
even like within the past couple of years,
I'll find myself thinking like
I need to get a book on chess
'cause I've never really
gotten good at chess.
No, I don't actually,
I mean maybe if I want to,
and I think it would be fun to learn,
but not just so I could have
like beat somebody at chess,
but I don't, I've just observed like
even the games we play on GMM,
like the guessing, the countdown
game gets super competitive
in that game, because--
I believe I have a chance.
Yeah, because you're
really good at that game.
Or like the Pup Puck game.
I'm like, "Hey, this is a new one."
I don't have to lose every time.
But then at a certain point with like,
I lose this dart game every time,
it's like, well, that's kinda frustrating.
'Cause I feel like I do try on that one.
I'm not great at aim, but yeah.
It's like, I think there's--
And there's nothing wrong with that.
There's nothing.
No, I think we're at extremes because
I think that the thing
that could be wrong with it
is not willing to try something
and get better at something
in order to enjoy,
like the competition
part of it is, I mean,
if you can only point to
one example or two examples
on the show, given all the
things we compete against,
it's just not the thing
I'm most interested in.
So I don't think, I'm
certainly not competitive
to the same level that you are
because I'm not interested in winning.
I think what I'm getting at
is once the circumstances are set
and you're committed to the game,
I can see in your eyes
that you want to win.
That is very rare.
I think it takes a lot
for the circumstances
to be right.
I'm just saying in those moments.
And so--
But I am generally not
competitive, like sports.
But there are people--
Like games.
But there are people
who, okay, Catch Phrase,
you're super competitive in Catch Phrase.
I think it's--
And there are people who aren't.
I think you're misinterpreting that.
I think it's fun to be really into it,
like the theatricality of it.
But I don't really care if I win or lose.
Like a lot of times when
I play Catch Phrase,
I'll like, I'll give
clues in a very weird way
because I just think it's fun
and because if there's a timer.
I'm like, and it's gonna
go, I don't believe.
But there's also strategy in that.
Beat it, take it, doing weird clues
early on in the clock is
that there's a strategy.
'Cause then you give
it to the next person.
There's less time.
And then they get frustrated.
And this funny to watch them get upset,
but it's not about winning or losing.
It's just about the social dynamics
are a music thing--
I guess what I'm saying is
I have known people
who I would say are truly not competitive.
Like you can tell that they really,
at no point do they get engaged
to the point where they would
actually really wanna win.
It's like who, I don't,
and I just I'm saying that, okay.
I will definitely can see that
you're not as competitive as me,
but you're more competitive
than you give yourself credit.
I think I'm adaptable to,
sometimes when people are competitive
and that's how they're having a good time.
Like it's not fun to be,
it's a killjoy to not participate.
And the way you participate
because you're competitive.
I think you're misinterpreting me
as being competitive when
I'm just being playful.
Like I'm actually like, I'm here to play.
I'm here, I don't,
I want to contribute to
the fun that's being had
and the climate is competition,
but I personally am not driven,
I'm driven by having a good time.
And I don't, and I know, I have one,
I can either be competitive
and that will be fun for everybody.
Or I'll the person who's not.
And then it's a Debbie
Downer, it destroys it.
So when you do something well
and don't think about it,
I think you're also isolating it to games,
but like anything, well,
anything that you do in your career,
like I'm trying to do this well,
I'm trying to be a certain way about this.
I'm trying to create this piece of,
I guess my definition of competition
is just much wider as well,
because what I'm saying is
I feel like competitiveness
is one of the elements that has gotten us
to where we're at in our career.
Like, and it is, I don't mean like,
Ooh, I want to get more views
than this other channel.
I mean, sometimes it
might come down to that,
but it's not really that.
It's more like I'm
competing against myself.
Like ultimately everybody wants
to be important in some way.
And people who are in their entertainment
kind of achieve that
and find their purpose
a lot of times in, eliciting
a reaction from people.
And I would say that you are actually
even more focused and
committed to getting a reaction
from a crowd or from an
individual than I am.
You think about, like the
way that you're super,
I'm much less concerned about things like,
where is this thing and
where is the camera?
And am I showing, am I opening
this box in the right way?
In my mind, that's all competitive nature.
It's like, you have a commitment
to excellence and you may,
you're thinking about competitiveness
in like I'm throwing a ball
faster than a person or not,
but like, you actually care
about that stuff more than I do.
And I would call that sort of purse.
I would almost say it's
a relentless pursuit
of doing things in a certain way.
Perfection is not, I mean,
is attained by comparison
to like a standard.
But I think it's a stretch to
say that that's competition,
like I'm competing against the standard.
I also think it is, I think
it's a little muddied by,
I don't know.
Do you do you get from
me in this conversation
that like I judge you
for being competitive?
Yes.
Okay, so we're breaking in Kiko,
I don't envy what the
decisions you've had to make
in editing this, but apparently
Kiko has decided that
what you just heard was
like the truncated point
and the end of this episode--
And the reason being--
And then next week, you'll
get the continuation
for over an hour of the
rest of our conversation,
which like veered deep into
introspection and arguments
and an apology.
I'm sensationalizing,
'cause I really do want--
It got very deep.
I want him to listen to part two,
'cause I think it's,
I'm gonna be thinking a lot about it.
Just to set the stage,
'cause you're gonna have to
wait a week to listen to it.
So as you know, we were
talking about board games
and I've talked about this many times,
I've talked about my theory that Link is
just as competitive as me in quotes.
And that led to a conversation--
And I've never liked
it when you said that.
And I don't know exactly why.
About a, boy it got very,
it just got very deep.
It got very personal, very
vulnerable from both sides.
And we ended up talking about
the dynamics of our friendship
and our creative partnership
and how we think differently
about it and what we, how
we think the same about it.
And I just didn't want that conversation
to get buried at the end
of an entire episode,
about something else,
about board games and movies and our kids.
And so you may be frustrated with us
that we're making you
wait another week for it,
but we poured a lot of ourselves into it
and I don't want it to get buried and--
And not to be competitive,
but if you're frustrated,
you can drag your frustration at Link.
'Cause this was his idea.
I don't like having a two
and a half hour podcast
when it's like--
I believe this is the
right choice actually.
And it puts something front and center
that we want the most people to listen to
and not lose heart before they get to it.
And it allows us to not have to sit down
and record another episode...
Which is always good.
So it's a win win.
So stay tuned to next week for that.
But for now use hashtag EarBiscuits,
let us know about board games.
I mean, we've just finished having
the part of the conversation
you're going to next week.
So it's like, this is so--
I think we said some good
things about board games.
Is it Ketan or Catan?
You could tell us about that.
I'm sure you would like to
recommend board games to us
or any type of family oriented games
that we can continue to borrow--
We're not a family,
just ones where you put the kids to bed
and things get dirty.
Those are good games too.
Hashtag EarBiscuits and we
will speak at you next week,
which will be the continuation--
But we're about to
record an intro for that.
That makes sense of it.
So there's lots of different pieces.
Let's do that now.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.